[Musik]
unser hammer der woche im saarländischen
ensdorf liegt der bahnhof ganz am rand
der gemeinde deshalb will die kommune
den hals seit jahren mitten ins zentrum
verlegen das lehnt die deutsche bahn
aber kategorisch ab dafür will sie den
alten bahnhof jetzt umbauen eine neue
unterführung soll er samt aufzug
schächten aber ohne aufzüge ihre ja das
ist natürlich schwachsinn also was soll
man mit den aufzug schächten die gebaut
werden aber ohne aufzüge
ich frage mich was das für ein sinn
macht wir bezahlen als kunden so viel
geld uns ist total sinnlos ich fahre
jeden tag von ensdorf nach saarbrücken
und ich kenne den zustand her des
bahnhofs ganz gut auch die parksituation
die situation für fahrräder die
anbindung an den öffentlichen nahverkehr
so buss es ist eigentlich eine
katastrophe wie immens dorf zum bahnhof
will hat es nicht leicht es gibt keinen
anschluss ans busnetz und für pendler
gibt es nur ein paar unbeleuchtete
parkplätze eine echte zumutung deshalb
will die kommune die bahnhof seit jahren
direkt an den marktplatz verlegen
davon will die bahn nichts wissen die
verlegung sei zu teuer
außerdem könne man auf dieses
rangiergleis nichts verzichten das
führte früher ins ensdorfer bergwerk sei
2012 ist das aber dicht was man am
satten grün im gleisbett sehr schön
erkennt egal jetzt soll also für
geschätzte 4,9 millionen euro am alten
bahnhof der bahnsteig erhöht werden dazu
kommt eine neue unterführung mit aufzug
schächten aber ohne aufzüge die sollen
erst später kommen und müssen vom land
und der gemeinde bezahlt werden im
rathaus sind sie sauer
ja wir haben das gefühl uns wird die
pistole auf die brust gesetzt entweder
machen wir es oder es passiert gar nicht
in münster bei der deutschen bahn kann
man die aufregung nicht verstehen
schriftlich heißt es lapidar die db
nimmt wünsche von anwohner innen und
reisende merzt die verlegung des
bahnhofs wurde daher in mehreren
machbarkeitsstudien geprüft im hinblick
auf die ergebnisse der studien ist eine
verlegung des bahnhofs nicht vorgesehen
für viele ensdorfer eine kurzsichtige
und falsche entscheidung die viel geld
kostet das ist ignorant das ist eine
frechheit wie man hier mit dem wunsch
der bevölkerung umgegangen wird es
werden hier circa fünf millionen euro
investiert ja für eine sache was für
mich wenig sinn macht im ems dorf hoffen
sie noch immer auf ein einlenken der
bahn ganz im sinne der viel geforderten
verkehrswende